we'll start with this guy okay now you
remember i said to you
kind of like your crutch your back up is
always when you're not sure you see
something you're like i don't know what
this looks like come back to this okay
come back to this they won't tell you
necessarily what the equation will be
unlike what i've done here even though
you can actually kind of give a
reasonable guess when you look at the
graph they'll show you the picture and
so you can think well what's that is it
going to be linear is it going to be a
quadratic and then you can apply this
logic and see what it gives you okay so
when you come over here
all this means is this
and we've seen these before okay so
essentially what's going to happen is
you're going to take this graph
and every time you have a positive value
that's fine right because it's just
going to leave it positive like so okay
but then what happens over here how
would you describe it
what you can actually have
okay fantastic just like i rubbed it off
but just like before this part only this
part will flip up right okay like so
so there's your graph you've got to make
sure it's off at the right angle okay
that these um these kinds of things
match up and remember you've got a grid
there okay so for instance um they'll
probably have i guess that'll be one
negative one
negative two
negative three so as a marker i will
have a look i will look at this
coordinate
this one this x value and i'll look to
see where it matches on your graph right
so where do you think it should be
it should be up at three shouldn't it
because it's been reflected is there's
symmetry here right and if it's not at
three if it's significantly above or
significantly below you have missed a
feature an attribute of this graph right
so that's how when the scale is given to
you you need to be extra careful
especially when it's just a straight
line
okay let's have a look at this guy right
now because there's an absolute value
there's going to be that same kind of
reflecting you know sort of bouncing
graph business okay
but being at the absolute values in a
completely different position you get
quite different behavior okay so
think about this in the in the 15 20
minutes that we've had to
dig into this concept
if you don't know what it looks like
straight away what should be your
immediate strategy
when this fails you go here okay here's
your fallback position all right so if
the absolute value of x is inside
right that means that this really equals
to 2 absolute value of x plus 3. does
that make sense
everywhere i got 3 sorry everywhere i
got x before i'm just substituting in
whatever's inside the brackets which in
this case is the absolute value of x
so how does the absolute value function
work when you've got a number out the
front okay well it can just go straight
inside
like so
okay so now you can picture what does
the absolute value
of 2x
look like
it's going to be just like this guy
right except it'll be fixed on the
origin yeah so if i could draw this in
dotted
there's the absolute value of 2x that
guy there okay
and now what do i do
i just i just raise it up don't i okay
so in fact this
this graph here the modified one has the
same
y-intercept as my original graph right
it's still 3.
so this dotted line absolute value of 2x
will move up 3 units and i'm going to
get this line
okay see that
that is the absolute value
inside the brackets
so here remember we were trying to word
what was happening okay
here we reject any negative values for y
okay if you're telling me okay y should
be negative i'm going to reverse that
okay
this is a little bit different isn't it
okay i'm refusing if you want to think
about it this way
any of these negative values for x they
all get washed out see how this is
negative 1 negative 2 negative 3 going
horizontally right so because the
absolute value is in there it ignores
that behavior and it just imagines that
it's growing in a positive way just like
this side is
okay right let's push a little further
what happens when you absolute values on
the other side
does anyone think they know what they
can have a guess as to what it looks
like just like
off bat
all right so let me see if you remember
from the last five minutes what's our
fallback position what should we do
instead of trying to do it visually
go back to the algebra right so you
write this
is that helpful
okay now
arguable whether it's helpful or not at
least if you're like me i'm just so not
used to having the absolute values on
why that i kind of look at this and my
brain goes boom
now you can deal with this you can deal
with this there's a couple of different
ways right you need to come back to
what was the absolute value how long ago
was it like not a rhetorical question
how long ago was it that you had a look
at absolute value
started midway through the year start of
the year
who remembers yeah you're not in action
at start of the year yeah so it's been a
while okay
do you remember there were a few
different ways to define what is the
absolute value of
something okay there are a few different
ways at least four that i can think of
okay
uh the most obvious one is what you guys
thought of over here which is
um take the positive value
looks like they need a key
on your right hand side there's big
shelves they're compact as they move
around and there's this
so just make sure you pick up the books
that's the part
and then bring the key back to it thank
you
these juniors they're too efficient okay
so
here's our here's a simple definition
okay but there are more sophisticated
more technical definitions does anyone
remember any of them
there's one
the second one yeah actually
ah good okay take the positive and the
negative now this is a bit funny because
you're like but i thought absolutely is
about taking the positive only okay so
the way they say this is there's a um a
two-sided definition right two-prong
definition for what the absolute value
of a is sometimes the absolute value of
a
is just a
but other times the absolute value of a
is
negative a
okay
pending some conditions does anyone
remember when is it this
and when is it
this there's a condition on it
okay fantastic so
when a is positive
right or equal to zero i don't care
really zero doesn't matter it doesn't
have any impact on his absolute value
you just take it back right so the
absolute value of 5 sure enough is just
5. okay
but it's
negative a when it's the other condition
the other inequality right when a is
negative does that make sense
so the absolute value of negative 5
because that's negative it's actually
negative negative 5 which of course is
5. okay so how can we take advantage of
this
in this scenario
how could we rewrite this algebraically
t's apart what it mean
okay y is equal to two x plus three so
this is we've got two two parts now okay
good
right
or alternatively instead of positive y
it'll be
negative y when
or if y is negative okay i probably
shouldn't have drawn all over my graph
but that'll actually be okay right so
now you can see right
have a look here
i have two graphs that make up this
piecemeal function okay
i've got what are the actual equations
of the two different blue branches this
branch it's the original
what's the equation over here
think about it we did it in the first
question
it's negative 2x
minus 3 isn't it right because it would
have collided with negative 3 over here
yeah what about over here still same
function here
what about this branch
i flipped over the x-axis but the um the
y-intercept is still the same isn't it
so it's not this guy it's going to be
that guy right
okay so now when you come over here what
does this look like well this part's
fine if y is greater than or equal to
zero so tell me
motion with your hands right
which part of this graph satisfies this
inequality
can you describe it
surely it's this part right
it's that part that part is still y is
greater than or equal to zero so that
retains the original equation right so
now you say well what about when y is
negative what about below the axis okay
what should the graph look like you tell
me
which way should it go
i think it'll look like this won't it
minus 2x minus 3 that's what happens
when this negative sign comes across the
other side so it's going to look like
this guy
yes
y equals negative two x
minus three why does it look like that
it's the same equation
this equation
matches
this equation
but we're looking at it for different
ranges right we're looking at it for
different domains here it's when y is
positive
here when y is negative
so you see they're all doing the same
flipping thing
that we know absolute value does but
they do it in different ways around
different points
okay